I just think about this Cat Williams
thing and I'm just like people are like
dude hell yeah Cat Williams telling the
truth you know telling the talking [__]
about everyone right he's talking [__]
about Kevin Hart he's talking talking
[__] about Joe Rogan he's talking [__]
about uh Cedric the Entertainer Steve
Harvey I mean dude every even people
that had no business he's talking [__]
about just
like and like I I I think Kevin I think
uh cat will is [__]
hysterical but everyone there are people
that are just like oh dude he's a hero
he speaks the truth thank God somebody's
saying it dude you
can't you can't have first of all my
favorite thing that he said was that uh
Kevin Hart was a plant an industry plant
which everyone's like knew it dude ever
since Soul Plane dude you cannot be a
[__] plant a Hollywood plant you as a
comedian people are either laughing with
you or
not I guess if you're in industry and
someone if if in the music industry and
someone just picks you to make an album
I is that a plan like what even is a
plan a plan is something that can only
be secretly a
spy it's like a government plan or a
plant PL like a plant in a house can be
a PL you can't be a
plant if you're what that what does that
mean the the the industry just picked
you to be in movies that's what it is
that's what acting
is H H who what does it mean unless
Kevin Hart is an undercover CIA agent
right unless he's his actually unless
he's actually his character in Central
Intelligence never saw it sometime you
know the big rock little Johnson movie
with the [__] I don't know if he was
the CIA guy probably The Rock was
but cuz the rock looks like the
rock um but dude he's not a plant
because of obviously and here's the
thing is that people are just like hell
yeah speaking the truth but really he's
just speaking he's just being
funny I don't like how I don't like how
Comics are [__] [__] dude like
they're [__] Live and Let Live I saw
a black comedian say uh online like yo
how come black comedians only are the
only comedians that tear down other
black comedians white comedians don't do
it I'm like bro I almost wrote to him
lol like they're just
it's it's it's so it's such it's such
[__] [__] to be doing that [__] and I
like Cat
Williams I never met
him I never met him but he's funny as
[__] though actually let's let's go to
this let's talk about the the Cat
Williams thing and let's let's play the
clip I meant to play it
earlier of course this isn't
working there we
go
[Music]
um
on let's talk about uh here we
go
oh this this are you related to uh
Luda no um related to the crossroads
where we were both
invited to an Illuminati thing and it
had to be one or the other of us and
decisions had to be made so it was both
of us we were equal one of us had to cut
off all their hair and couldn't do the
Sideburn thing no more with the points
and the next person they said was going
to get $200 million because they were
going to pay him 10 million a movie to
do 20 movies and that's how the
conversation happened one of those
persons turned out to be ludicrous and
the other person turned out to be Cat
Williams bro they don't do
that yeah he has the the he has those
and he want to shave it but what I don't
get is like he's breaking it down like
hey Hollywood execs come up and they
they hey dude you know what we got to
get ludicrous and Cat Williams in here
now there's a part that's great for only
either of
them you know what I
mean hey Luda hey Cat so look we're
thinking of making 20
movies like this is not how it
works we're thinking of making 20 movies
about cars now check this out the first
one it's going to be fine the second one
little crazy by the time I get to like
seven cars are going to be going outer
space it's going to be Bonkers and very
bad we want to give you one of you $200
million UPF front to be in 20 of these
movies but the key to it is you got to
shave who want I know one of you wants
it and one of you doesn't so what's it
going to
be and ludicrous was like I'll do it and
Cat Williams was like yeah cuz I
won't
also there's never been 20 sequels of
anything you know I don't even know if
there's 20 James Bond
movies let's keep going with this
interview now one person ended up with a
light-skinned ugly faed wife that's
never done a remember I told you that if
I say that it apply to seven people it's
part of what they give you okay I didn't
get it I'm not mad about it how much
money they
give 200
sir Fast and Furious is on what number
right
now want a me I might need get me one of
more
women look
say that's what they all end up saying
at the end of the
day I just don't
know look at he's talking [__] about
everybody yeah that's what he said
ludicrous wife's ugly Kevin told you it
won't go wear no dress until they
offered him the dress and then he put it
on what did he say
after I made my own decision duh but you
didn't make it before they brought it up
did you it's okay it's all right for a
fiveyear period every single movie that
Kevin Hart did was a movie that had been
on my desk that all I had said was just
can we take some of this step and
fetches [__] out and then I can do it
like it don't need to be overtly
homosexual cuz I'm not homosexual right
it doesn't need that funny right there's
truth in this me saying that and them
going oh yeah no problem and then going
to give it to this other guy and having
him do it just like it was and acting
like I'm a bad person because I keep
standing on my standard but I mean all
that's yeah that could be true you know
CU it's like dude they give you the
script they want you to do what they
want to do but but what I don't
understand is hey I don't want to and
this is not just Cat Williams this is
like like people think this oh dude I
don't want to like people think that if
you do a roll with a dress on as a man
then oh they got you you're in the
Illuminati like I and they also talk
about how black actors black actors talk
about how black actors do it bro every
single white movie star has dressed in a
dress in a movie every single
one who pick one Schwarzenegger done
it
uh I don't know I'm just saying random
ones you know Michael Douglas probably
done
it Bruce Willis Michael Keaton they all
it it is cheap though you know
um but my favorite thing was this
ludicrous
responded in a freestyle which is by the
way by the way I think that that's the
right way to do it because because first
of
all it doesn't seem like you're serious
about it it seems like you're having fun
and also you're ludicrous so who gives a
[__] you know but look this was the frey
whatever's heavy on my heart is always
on my mind like snoop's cannabis
Shredder I'm always on my grind they
Throwing Shade cuz [__] could never
take my shine I bring my watch
collection on myet let me take
myne I'm aging like Benjamin so far this
is just
has nothing to do with Cat Williams you
know that's
okay the pendulum swing Jesus with
diamond Thorns ludicrous swaddled in
Gucci Linens when I was born Illuminati
only
AUD and there we go now that
is quite possibly the worst hip-hop bar
I've ever heard in my life not never
Illuminati only udina
naughty wow
dude
only now married with kids the evolution
of life never been a clout Chaser never
say [__] for likes rip John Singleton
you never have to flex when you earn
every one of your Fast and Furious
checks afro with the side burs I mean
you know what does earn mean in this
situation show up to
work ludicrous goes like this is
ludicrous oh him in F yeah that's
Myans
[Music]
nice I am not a Luda fan but I'm I'm
happy he did that 9.3 million
views
[Music]
crazy